راويه تدرين بامكانك ان تفتحي حساب بنك
واداره لسنوات دون مغادره منزلك وانت
قاعده او حتى التعامل مع موظف البنك لحتى
يمكن موظف
هذه مشاهدينا هي فقره البنوك الرقميه هيا
ببساطه خدمات مصرفيه تتم بالكامل عبر
الانترنت اصبحت شائعه بشكل كبير بعد وباء
كورونا المصارف الرقميه قد تكون مستقله
بذاتها ولا وجود لها على ارض الواقع او
تابعه لشركه تجاره الكترونيه او وحدات
تابعه لبنوك تقليديه والاهم انها تعمل
طوال اليوم ولا تلزمك بمواعيد عمل محدده
مثل البنوته البنوك التقليدي هذه البنوك
تساعد الجميع على الوصول الى خدمات
المصرفيه خاصه هؤلاء الذين يعيشون في
اماكن تعاني من نقص في البنوك
فلان مشاهدينا بضيفنا من الكويت عبد الله
احجم رئيس الخدمات المصرفيه الشخصيه
والخدمات المصرفيه الخاصه اهلا بك استاذ
عبد الله معنا استاذ عبد الله دعنا نفهم
بدايه يعني او اذا بتقدر تشرح للناس
العاديين اللي ما عندهم خبره اللي مثلي
اللي ما عندهم خبره كتير
شؤون المصرفيه والبنوك شو الخيارات
المتاحه بالنسبه لالي فيما يتعلق
بالحسابات البنكيه لو ما كانت في احد
البنوك الموجودين بالمدينه اللي انا مقيمه
فيها
يا اهلا وسهلا ومرحبا فيكم جميعا وشكرا
على الاستضافه
العمل مصرفي
تطور
بمحاكاه القطاعات الاخرى المكمله للعمل
المصرفي مثل عمليات التحويل والساحب
والايداع واتمام المعاملات من شراء وبيع
وغيره
فاذا نذكركم في في الماضي عمليه التسوق
كانت لازم تكون فيزيكال بشخصك واذا كانت
المنتج غير متوفر في الدوله الواحد يضطر
انه ينتظر سفرته لاقتناء هذا المنتج
تطور الموضوع الى انك انت تشتري الحين
خلال
فصار الموضوع
بهذه البساطه
ولابعد من كذلك انك انت ما تدري المنتج تم
ارساله لبيتك من خلال الدوله نفسها ولا من
خارج من سرعه التوصيل محاكاه
انك تطور العمل المصرفي في القطاع المصرفي
وانتقل من الفروع التقليديه الى
الويب الى الموبايل ابليكيشن واللي لا
استحسان كبير وصاحبه مجموعه من التطور في
عمليات
الستلنت واداء المعاملات من النقد الى
الشيكات الى البطاقات الى الدفع عن طريق
الموبايل هذا ادى الى خلق
بنك قطاع جديد في البنوك ما يسمى في
الديجيتال بنك يقدم جميع خدماته من خلال
فصاحبه سهوله في عمليه فتح الحساب في
عمليه تحويل في العمليات كلها مثل ما
تفضلتوا والحين الواحد
عذرا بس اسمح لي ان اليوم مثلا يختلف عن
الاون لاين بنك لكل بنك موجود الخدمات
المصرفيه البنكيه عبر الانترنت لكل بنك
تقليدي موجود لانه انا واحد من الناس يمكن
عندي خبره بانه انا فتحت في احد البنوك في
احدى الدول الاوروبيه وتحديدا خلينا نقول
في بريطانيا لكن بعد فتره طالبوني بانه
يجب ان اقدم لهم
ربما الكشف الضريبي انا ما عندي كشف ضريبي
انا رايح سائح حتى لا اشيل فلوس معاي حولت
الى هذا البنك كل البنوك هذه الان
الالكترونيه هي نفس الطريقه
هي هي البنك الالكتروني هو في النهايه بنك
يقع تحت نطاق
الجهات الرقابيه لهذه الدوله
لكن
التعامل
والاشتراطات قد تكون يعني احنا نقول في
المينيموم ريكوايرمنت من الجهات الرقابيه
قد تكون اعلى من كذا في في بعض البنوك لكن
لا تقل عن هذه الاشتراطات المطلوبه على
سبيل المثال الحين وانت في في دولتك طبعا
في خطه استراتيجيه لهذا الموضوع خلينا
نبسط اخوي عبد الله الكويتي او سعودي حاب
انه يسافر الى لندن يقضى بدل ما يشيل وياه
فلوس
ويحولها وربما الف باوند او الفين او عشره
الاف او المبلغ ايهما يكون هل يقدر عن
طريق هذا البنوك شلون
هل يحتاج اقامه في بريطانيا عشان يعمل هيك
بالضبط
بالضبط بالضبط وجدنا في في في جروب بوبيان
هناك نقص في هذا
في هذه الخدمه ولذلك انشانا بنك ديجيتال
نومو في بريطانيا والان خلال دقائق معدوده
تستطيع ان تفتح حساب في بنك نومو وتحول له
من خلال بطاقه واحده تفتح مجموعه حسابات
بعملات مختلفه في نومو وتروح دوله تتعامل
في اليورو بنفس البطاقه يتم خصم من حسابك
في اليورو في نونو اذا رحت مثلا لندن
ينخصم الاسترليني في نومه
مرتادين بريطانيا
بالضبط وغير غير غير شذي اذا حضرتك من ضمن
اللي يسافرون كثير على بريطانيا وحاب
تقتني الحين من خلال الابلكيشن ممكن تقدم
على تمويل ويتم تمويلك من خلال الابلكيشن
حتى
اقتراض بدون اقامه على ما يبدو طيب شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا من الاقتراب حتى الاقتراب
عبد الله المحزم رئيس الخدمات المصرفيه
الشخصيه والخدمات المصرفيه الخاصه كان
معنا من الكويت شكرا جزيلا لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التن